all right let's jump into this first
story from msn.com Health shocker Jamie
Foxx left quote paralyzed and blind from
blood clot in his brain after receiving
covid-19 vaccine Source claims now right
there those two words should send off
alarm bells for you because I don't know
who this source is but what we have is
basically a communist formerly of the
daily I believe the New York daily news
the New York daily news saying that his
Source has confirmed to him these things
so it is a reporter saying I have a
source
that's never usually good enough for me
to be completely honest so take this out
with a grain of salt Jamie Foxx's family
claimed that he actually was recovering
in and out of the hospital and was
playing pickleball so paralyzed and
blind is a bit extreme and I want to so
I see this story trending and I just
want to say be careful with it because
if you run out the door and I say aha
it's true because it's tens of thousands
of people tweeting about this
and then a week from now he shows up and
he's like man you all are crazy like
there's none of this is happening you're
gonna look really dumb yeah partial
paralyzation and blindness is possible
too like a little bit of loss of ocular
ability and maybe it's harder to move an
arm but he could still get up and play
Pickleball so it's possible that all
three yeah true dude could have crapped
his pants you know what I mean like what
we heard about it is that he was on the
set of a film he had some kind of
medical episode and he's been in and out
of the hospital so it's been very
secretive and just like that football
player remember that guy who Tamar
Hamlin yeah he fell down in the field
and everyone's like oh he's he's he's
paralyzed or whatever and then sure
enough he literally shows up on TV
totally fine you had fetterman they
reported that he was completely he was
reportedly brain dead and he's back I
mean he's still having he's still
struggling and everything but he's as he
was before he went to the hospital too
I'm not saying it's not true I'm just
saying be careful with this stuff take
it with a grain of salt and uh talk to
your doctor about what makes sense for
you find good doctors don't rely on the
internet for medical information but uh
I do think the story is still very uh
interesting and because it's trending I
think we should talk about it so we have
this story they say horrific an end to
stress this point I want to make sure
everyone at YouTube and all the Liberals
and all the leftists and all the big
Pharma sycophants see this this is
msn.com reporting this and they are
certified by newsguard 100 out of 100 so
if I can't use this as a source I don't
know what to tell you because we're
gonna here you go
horrific Health details have have been
revealed regarding Jamie Foxx's
mysterious medical State the Django
Unchained star is said to be partially
paralyzed and blind in addition to a
series of other complications after
receiving the covid-19 vaccine Hollywood
journalist AJ benza claimed after
speaking to a source close to Fox quote
Jaime had a blood clot in his brain
after he got the shot he did not want
the shot but the movie he was on he was
pressured to get it confessed The
podcaster Who formerly worked as a
columnist for the New York daily news as
well as the host of the E-Series
Mysteries and Scandals during an
appearance on Dr Drew pinskey's online
show ask Dr Drew
quote the blood clot in the brain caused
him at that point to be partially
paralyzed and blind benza alleged as he
insisted his Insider was someone in the
room with first-hand knowledge of Fox's
hospitalization I am thinking is that
why he blew up on the set a week before
his medical emergency happened the
veteran journalist asked Pinsky is that
why he fired three or four people
because he has had it with these
mandates Fox was admitted to the
hospital after suffering a medical
complication on Thursday April 11th
although specific details on his current
health status have been difficult to
discover
the 55 year old's medical woes mounted
while filming his latest movie Back In
Action the movie also starring Cameron
Diaz has moved forward with production
without Fox using a body double in his
place so they do go into stress
that uh his daughter Cory Corin or
Corrine said that he was playing
pickleball saying sad to see how the
media is running wild my dad has been
been out of the hospital for weeks
recuperating in fact he was playing
pickleball yesterday thanks for everyone
prayers and support we have exciting
work uh work announcement coming next
week
so this guy then says it's all lies in
baloney if you read into what they were
saying early on quote he is
communicating with us that doesn't mean
talking that could mean anything writing
sign language I know those little code
words benza continued to assume Fox's
current capabilities then you tell me
your father is playing pickleball give
me a break there's a great shot of
secrecy around Jamie Foxx so we don't
know right what we do know is I think we
have uh TMZ reported he's doing physical
rehab in Chicago family by his side and
we don't know exactly why but they why
he's at the facility what his medical
issue was they say well we don't know
exactly what happened to Jaime or why
he's there we know the facility
specializes in stroke recovery traumatic
brain injury rehab spinal cord injury
rehab and cancer Rehabilitation they say
there's no reason to believe that he has
cancer but to be completely honest if
we're just doing if we're just
speculating at this point maybe his
medical episode is related to cancer I
honestly I have no idea but uh welcome
to Big celebrity news trending on
Twitter what happened and I want to
throw in there Eric Clapton real quick
who uh his hands were partially
paralyzed and he freaked out after he
got the vaccine so I don't know what you
guys think
uh I think that if they have a body
double in the movie then he's got some
serious health issues at the moment
otherwise they wouldn't have had to get
a body double to do the job well he's
clearly I mean his daughter is saying
what he's out of the hospital now yeah
yeah if he's if he's able to play
Pickleball he would be able to star in
the movie though so that that whole
pickleball narrative doesn't make sense
if they have a body double for him for
the movie and the fact that they're
saying that he's in rehab whether for
whatever reason yeah I think that
there's something going on maybe it's
not necessarily the kova jab related but
it could be something else I mean it's
something there's something in the
language that makes it sound like yeah
he could have had a blood clot and he
could have had paralyzation but now he's
recovering from it so no he doesn't have
that because they could have fixed it I
mean the language is interesting the way
that the article's written and the way
that the daughter talks about it sounds
like something bad happened they've
fixed it and he's recovering from it so
no he technically doesn't have that you
know currently right now at this moment
playing pickleball I mean I'm looking at
the things that this place specializes
and if you have a spinal cord injury
you're not playing pickleball so that
leaves the other serious things so
unless and and it's just what two weeks
of rehab and then he was back to playing
pickleball or is he like in a wheelchair
with one arm slumped over yeah
what is pickleball anyway oh yeah it's
like it's kind of it's something old
people play ah this is uh I play
Pickleball combined some elements tennis
badminton and table tennis no I do I
love playing pickleball we play at the
gym um it is kind of like a table it's
like a table tennis mixed with tennis
but it's a smaller quarter and like
beach tennis almost
I've never played Beach tennis like that
yeah it's those big wooden paddles right
it's small well it's really small
paddles and you actually play with like
a wiffle ball and you can get those
things moving though I think I've seen
this yeah like I've seen this it's just
a smaller smaller court but you gotta
move and even if you're playing doubles
you gotta move do you do you do that at
the home Sarah
no I do it at the gym it's possible that
Jamie Fox loves pickleball and that in
his recovery wants to get out there and
play even if he's playing poorly just to
get his motor skills it's just blowing
again what if he's like in a wheelchair
and he's just like slumped over and they
put the pickleball thing in his hand and
he's not moving and they're like he's
playing dude he's one of my favorite
actors man this is Horror Story yeah I
thought he was gray and Spider-Man to be
honest and then and then everything he
does is turns to Gold he's playing Ray
Charles did you guys oh my God that was
brilliant I've only seen Clips but good
Lord the man's amazing amazing I am
Wanda from In Living Color I was
watching some Keenan Ivory Wayans
earlier today even his music his music's
fantastic too he's trained pianist he
went to college for a piano wow that's
why he could email the audition Ian
really likes there's a show called The
Mask singer where they have people dress
up and like like furries and sand and
um the every single year that they have
this every single person who's a male
that sounds amazing thing that sings
they're like that's Jamie Foxx you know
that's that's how that's like that's
their person it's almost like a running
joke now at this point that he's
definitely got the voice I've got like
this love I remember on In Living Color
I don't know if you guys watched it in
the beginning 19 late 80s or something
he came on as the new guy like in the
second or third season and he was like
the kind of the outsider had to figure
out am I even funny everyone's like who
is this guy he's a joke and then he made
that Wanda character where it was like
that cross-eyed woman with the blonde
wig he's playing and he's always like
Tommy Lee Davidson's like ah you know he
wants to make out
um and after that he won my heart and it
was like just just this is the new guy
you know he overcame being the new guy
to become one of the greats of all time
I love you Jamie oh I mean the the going
blind after playing Ray Charles is a
little bit uh
I I really do think this is a strong
possibility he's gonna show up in like a
week completely fine I hope so and I
feel like dude this gossip stuff was
click bait whenever somebody goes goes
private for whatever reason then people
just run run whatever they can because
it's going to generate traffic and I you
know we were actually thinking do we
which medical story do we run Joe Biden
collapsing on stage and uh you know fall
he tricked on a sandbag I guess or Jamie
Foxx and it's just like this story is is
picking up steam because it hits all
those buzzwords it's got everything it's
got a celebrity it's got a movie being
shut down it's got covid vaccination
it's got mysterious illness so everybody
wants to know what's happening and then
everyone's giving you the most
Sensational output possible and I'm like
maybe but don't be surprised if in a
week he comes out and he's like man
y'all are crazy I hope he does yeah I
want to be wrong but think about how you
let it off though too this is the
mainstream media so it's and they're
running you know anti-covet vaccines
which is the exact opposite of what they
would have been doing a year ago so that
should give you some confidence that
that's possibly what's going on it could
be some kind of damage control that
they're laying I don't know but remember
and remember when that when the football
player collapsed remember they had
somebody show up to the stadium and he
was like all like dressed in you never
even saw his face oh they did the waving
from the window same thing that's why
I'm saying I think a lot of this is
publicity stunts because Demar Hamlin
ended up doing a press conference
clearly discernably him not that long
afterwards and so what happens is two
things you discredit the conspiracy
theorists who are like ah we knew and
then all of a sudden he's like ah here I
am you're crazy and it's like oh you're
crazy I remember after the Demar Hamlin
thing I was I was hanging out and uh I
was out at the uh the poker tables and
the people they were like dude he was he
was just waving to the crowd what are
you talking about I didn't say anything
I didn't like I'm not someone who goes
out and be like did you hear the crazy
conspiracy here's what I believe I was
like what's going on with that Hamlin
thing like uh they're claiming that he
he's paralyzed or whatever or like he
fell down what happened with that and
they're like nothing's going on it's all
nonsense he was he was at the stadium
waving to people not that people are
crazy and I'm like uh how about that
that's what they thought but if you
watched the video you were like yo what
is this clearly not him yeah but then
later he comes out and you can clearly
see it's him so I I think that probably
was a publicity stunt they were like hey
here we'll do this now that he's sick
we're gonna get a lot of hits and we're
gonna boost his profile send out someone
to act all weird generate a ton of press
and conspiracies and then he comes out
and everything's fine so I wouldn't be
surprised not that Jamie Foxx needs
press to be really honest yeah seriously
the only conspiracy thing I can think of
is if the people like I'm not saying
that they did this but some company that
had created uh coveted vaccines is like
all right let's see this story where it
makes it look like the coveted vaccine's
the bad guy but then when they find out
that it wasn't the coveted vaccine we'll
be off the hook and then they'll think
all these other conspiracies about the
vaccine are all so bad we're wrong and
we'll be off the hook so seed bad info I
don't think that's what happened sounds
like an experiencing Theory but the
whole like injury after the covet
vaccine does not imply that the covet
vaccine did this to the guy it's rare
it's worded in a way that it kind of
insinuates it but it doesn't mean that
no I'm not saying it didn't but it
doesn't
Hollywood celebrity gossip that people
want to latch on to people on the left
are saying like this is fake news you
shouldn't tweet it people on the right
are being like whoa this is reported by
this is being carried by MSN the
original reporting is Okay magazine but
MSN which is certified by News Guard 100
out of 100 must have checked it or
something or this is this is the kind of
stuff they put out so Microsoft news MSN
is that what that stands for Microsoft
news this is Microsoft and Microsoft
owns I think it's Microsoft network and
Microsoft owns uh the 100 fact check
msn.com is certified by newsguard 100
out of one Microsoft owns newsguard and
MSN they have a contract with them
Bill Gates
I don't think Bill Gates is directly
involved with Microsoft oh yeah yeah
yeah but so there it is I mean if the
headline says it and newsguard certified
it I don't know what else to tell you
other than you know make sure you're
getting sound medical advice from a good
medical professional pray for Jamie Foxx
yeah thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time